five adult specimens of scp-939 were  selected for testing with the clockworks  ruff produced an output of a pile of  bone splinters broken teeth and pieces  of translucent red tissue this tissue  continued to move and twitch on the  occasional basis for several hours  before stopping the specimen run through  the machine on course produce several  neat organized piles of tissue including  its muscles ground up bones teeth skin  esophagus and 15 kilograms of rotten  human flesh with a d-class id tag on top  when the next specimen was input on one  to one the output was redacted the next  specimen was placed on the setting fine  and it produced the exact same specimen  of adult scp-939  the only noticeable difference was that  it had stopped breathing on the setting  very fine the experiment produced a pile  of smoldering white ash